a few weeks ago a 66 year old handyman
named Lawrence Herr was installing a
mailbox outside of a home in Kenner
Louisiana boiling away in the heat
working past retirement age to provide
for his sick nine-year-old mother and
that's when two men in their 20s Taj
Matthews and Maurice Holmes drove by and
unlike Lawrence Herr Taj and Maurice
were not productive members of society
they were not the kinds of people you'd
want living in your neighborhood or
anywhere near your kids Maurice Holmes
had just gotten out of prison on a
six-year sentence for domestic violence
and that day Maurice Holmes and Taj
Matthews were supposed to be at their
jobs at IHOP but they pretended to be
sick and a few hours after getting out
of work they passed Lawrence Herr for
the first time as he was working on the
mailbox surveillance footage shows that
the two men drove by and then made a
u-turn and passed by Lawrence Herr again
and then they made another U-turn and
they drove past a second time and then
another u-turn on the third pass Maurice
Holmes handed a nine millimeter pistol
to Taj Matthews who then proceeded to
shoot her in the back Lawrence Herr bled
out next to the mailbox as the two men
drove away